[Music]
good morning live from paris well after
a closely fought election the results in
the end was not as close as some people
were predicting emanuel macron is now
the first president in 20 years to win a
second term after seeing off the
challenge from his far-right opponent
marine le pen he's made a promise to
unite his country which in his words is
riddled with doubts and divisions but as
the news filtered through of his win
hundreds of people took to the streets
to protest in at least six french cities
the riot police were out here in the
capital here's the results
well the election a result gives macron
a 58.54
of the vote while marine le pen has
41.46
sky's adam parsons reports now from
paris in the end the president won this
race with remarkable ease a walk in the
park but one that came after a fight
our country is full of doubts and full
of divisions
we will have to be strong
[Applause]
this was not a euphoric speech there was
no triumphalism he thanked his opponents
and looked forward to the future
emmanuel macron's often been accused of
being aloof and elitist and more
interested in the european union than he
is in his own country but this
is a celebration of frenchness we've had
the national anthem there are endless
flags and it's all in front of the
eiffel tower this is macron saying to
his people that after this overwhelming
victory he wants to be the president for
each and every one of them
[Music]
for the people who came to spectate
relief but not really jubilation i vote
for the first two but not for the second
because
i want either president these are pretty
dead he reminded everyone that
the values of democracy and the french
republic were more important
le pen supporters had gathered in hope
of a close finish but as soon as the
exit polls appeared the game was up
five years ago she was demolished in the
presidential runoff
this time it was nearer but still the
gap was wide
she seemed unrepentant
anife
tonight i'm worried that the next five
years
well i hope that they won't be
the same as before and i hope that
emmanuel
macron will try to repair
these splits in our
country macron
enjoyed the feeling of victory in the
party that followed but he knows that
many people voted for him simply to stop
le pen
rather than because of their faith in
his leadership
[Applause]
and that sense of discontent
reverberated across france as the result
was announced
in towns across the country and here in
paris
anti-macron protests led to violent
clashes with police
[Music]
in june france will hold parliamentary
elections and in those
he may be bruised
macron knows that even in victory his
country remains fractured
adam parsons sky news paris
[Applause]
well we can talk now to uh correspondent
ali fortescue who is also in paris and
it feels ali doesn't it that the scale
of the victory is obviously emphatic but
at the same time there's an awful lot of
people who are unhappy with the results
the minority of course take him to the
streets
[Music]
yeah that's exactly right you know
france today waking up to another five
years of emmanuel macron but waking up
to those really unsettling images of
protests across france hundreds of
people gathered in paris most notably uh
placed republic where we saw riot police
tear gas being used to break up
protesters we've seen hundreds of people
protesting too in places like marseille
and not in lyon where people were
chanting nemac
le pen neither macron nor le pen and
that has been the sort of theme of this
election in many ways an unpacked
popularity contest and a lot of
votes that weren't even cast people who
abstained because they didn't want to
vote for emmanuel macron or marine le
pen the challenge for macron now is
going to be healing those wounds we
heard him yesterday i think sounding
more humble than he was five years ago
saying that he wants to be a president
for all people but clearly these were
two people that didn't just have small
policy differences they had completely
different visions for france he knows
that the challenge now is going to be
bringing this country together
and thank you uh very much ali ali
forskou there in paris it does feel like
that is the story of the election really
an emphatic uh victory for emmanuel
macron but underneath that of course
deep divisions remaining many people are
unhappy with that final uh runoff well
that's all from us in paris for now
right back to you in the studio neil
sophie thanks very much indeed
uh let's take you straight to cave where
we have been hearing from the u.s
secretary of state more money has been
handed out
to the ukrainians let's find out what's
going on
continue to do
uh to ensure that we get them as much
assistance uh as possible as quickly as
possible
uh so
our focus uh in the meeting was to
talk about those things that would
enable us to win the current fight and
also build for tomorrow
and and uh again a very productive
discussion we talked about security
force assistance uh and we talked about
training and we also
talked about uh
the
key things that we're going to discuss
in the session that i'll conduct
tomorrow at ramstein with a number of
ministers of defense and chiefs of
defense this session is focused on doing
things to generate additional capability
and capacity for the ukrainian forces
and so it's a great opportunity
to get a good update from the child from
the minister of defense and from the
president on the things that they are
focused on the things that they need
that will enable us to have a more
productive discussion with the chads and
ministers of defense tomorrow
secretary houston secretary lincoln that
of course um sector if not the uh
secretary of state we'll uh listen uh
check the tape and see what we've had
from anthony blink and bring it to you
just a little bit later on in the
programme let's return to domestic
politics and joining us in the studio
once again minister for technology and
the digital economy chris philp lovely
to see you this morning mister good
morning um can we start if possible with
with france and uh president macron's uh
re-election has there been a collective
sigh of relief briefed in whitehall at
this uh this news well the uk government
is always ready to work with governments
of other countries once they're elected
we obviously congratulate president
macron on his victory
and look forward to you know working
closely with him i think the situation
in russia ukraine and elsewhere in the
world i think where there are you know
dangerous and uncertain forces of work
demonstrates the importance
of european democracies and free
countries around the world uh working
closely together and i think you know we
look forward to doing that with
president macron as he forms his new
administration i i think however there
will be a number of people in europe
this side of the channel and on the
other somewhat concerned about marine le
pen and the strength of the polling that
she enjoyed yep she has made her kind of
brand of far-right politics somewhat
more palatable but the two in five of
those who went to the polls in the
french presidential election voted for
her must be of some concern
well i think across western democracies
it's important that leaders listen i
think
electorates across the western world in
america across europe uh have concerns
about issues like cost of living like
immigration and it's important that
elected governments
uh listen to those concerns and respond
to them
and that applies you know in many
different countries and but as i say
look as far as the french election is
concerned you know we're looking forward
to working with president macron uh to
to meet the global challenges that we uh
as free western countries face together
for once in all of our chats let's
actually talk about something on your
brief shall we and the government now
moving forward with the tracy crouch
review putting fans at the center of
football once again just tell us just a
little bit more about it yeah well the
government committed in its 2019
election manifesto to have a fan-led
review that was set up about a year ago
and it was led by tracy crouch a
conservative mp and former sport
minister she spoke to i think hundreds
possibly even thousands of fans uh up
and down the country she made a number
of recommendations she had 10 strategic
recommendations which we're accepting
but important amongst those was the idea
that we need to have a statutory
football regulator so a regulator set up
in law by an act of parliament because
football clubs are critical parts of our
local community i'm a member of
parliament in croydon in south london
crystal palace is our local club and it
is a really important part of our local
community i went to my first game there
with my dad in
1991. um i'm taking my i've took my son
to the semi-final a week or two ago
unfortunately we lost i wasn't gonna
mention it we're gonna we're we're going
to the uh the home game against watford
at selas park in a couple of weeks so
it's something which i think you know um
by you know it's intergenerational right
families do this together it's part of
the local community
so when a club goes bankrupt and and
potentially disappears
barry and mackelsfield have done
uh derby county obviously in all kinds
of difficulties at the moment and other
clubs have come very close that is
something which really affects the heart
of communities it makes a football club
different to a normal business and
that's why this regulator statutory
regulator will make sure that football
clubs are in a financially healthy
position
and owners don't get into the position
where they kind of gamble recklessly
with the club's financial future by
spending way way too much more than they
can afford and putting the club's future
into jeopardy has happened in those
cases that i just mentioned i think a
number of people that we will be very
intrigued by by the owners and the
owners and directors test that is also
going to be brought in i mean it's a
very topical issue we all know that the
sale of chelsea is going through at the
moment can we just be clear would that
apply retrospectively to whoever takes
over at chelsea fc well the so the
intention behind the new test which
would be administered by the regulator
rather than by the football authorities
as at the moment as a transfer of
responsibility for doing that test would
apply not just at the
point of takeover but it would also
apply um from time to time on an ongoing
basis as as well the details are going
to be set out by my colleague the sport
minister
in parliament uh later on today but it
will be an ongoing test not a one-time
test and it will it'll be wider than the
current one so look at questions of
integrity uh financial resources
capability and capacity those kind of
questions to make sure the people who
are taking on custodianship
of such an important cultural asset like
a like a football club uh the people are
gonna that are gonna handle it properly
can we talk about the political story of
the weekend and it of course involves
angela raynor and that article in the
mail on sunday when you read what was
written by the mail on sunday's
political editor what was your response
i was appalled i was appalled that um
that sentiment was being expressed it's
offensive uh it's misogynistic the prime
minister and cabinet ministers have been
absolutely right to roundly condemn that
sentiment and to offer support to angela
uh rayner on this issue i've never heard
anyone uh say anything like that or even
hinted it and if i did i would be
disgusted and appalled nobody should
have to
suffer the kind of misogynistic um abuse
which that sentiment amounts to can i
can i take it from from what you said
then that the whips will be finding out
who said it and disciplining them
accordingly
well i think if it ever comes out who
said that then i imagine they would be
subject to discipline now yeah but the
reason i ask is that as things stand we
have had a couple of tweets sent by the
prime minister we understand that a
whatsapp message was sent but you know
there is a story of course in all of
this the story is that five of your
colleagues or a number of your
colleagues chose to brief against an
incredibly senior female labour
politician
in some of the most as you say yourself
say misogynistic terms so again i'll ask
does this not demand an internal
investigation by the whips by by the
party
well i think they'll be looking at
whether they know who said this i've got
no idea who said it and i say no one has
ever said anything like that to me or
even hinted at it and i think everybody
is appalled by um by the misogynistic
sentiment i think we all need to keep
the
tone of discourse in public life uh kind
of civil and respectful and focus on the
issues that our constituents expect us
to deal with not engage in this kind of
of what essentially is abuse
the reason i ask if there is more to be
done is to be fair at the weekend the
kind of conservative party's commitment
to to
sorting this mess out didn't really
appear terribly strong i want to show
our viewers um that which the the prime
minister tweeted uh in response to the
article and you know when you read the
words that they are pretty strong as
much as i disagree with angela raynor on
almost every political issue i respect
her as a parliamentarian and just
deplore the misogyny directed at her
anonymously today very very strong you
would say and then we saw this
from the dean doris as much as i
disagree with black the exact same tweet
what's going on here
well i mean they they share the same
view their colleagues and governments
they share the same view to the word
yeah i mean look i mean dean doran
nadine is my boss and she feels very
strongly about the place of women in
politics and that this sort of abuse is
unacceptable i'm sure she'll have
discussed it with the prime minister um
they'll have reached the same view and
they've used the same words there's
nothing surprising that two colleagues
in government have exactly the same view
and use the same words there is nothing
surprising about two human beings
sitting down at a keyboard and tapping
out exactly the same sentence
construction they've got the same view
on this issue
honestly you're trying to maintain that
the cultural secretary didn't copy and
paste this well it wasn't something that
was sent to her these aren't her own
words they're clearly not their own
words because they were said by the
prime minister 15 minutes look i mean
i've heard dean talk about this kind of
issue in private quite a lot and i can
tell you the sentiments being expressed
there are sentiments i've heard her
express countless times over the over
the last uh nine months that i've i've
worked with her so it doesn't surprise
me
at all that she's expressing herself so
strongly but nor does it surprise me
that she and the prime minister are
saying exactly the same thing
if they were saying different things
you'd be asking me about that wouldn't
you i would but i wouldn't be asking you
about this if she'd use slightly
different words you know it is clearly
not her own thoughts that she may think
that but she's chosen to copy it
directly from the prime minister the
reason i ask is of course we are in an
election cycle an election cycle which
looks like it could be
is it fair to say these local elections
could be pretty challenging for the
conservatives well i think local
elections mid-term tend to be
challenging for for any government um
where you know of both colours if you
look back over the history of the last
20 or 30 years midterm local elections
always
always pose challenges and very often
they also reflect local conditions so
again we've got local elections in
croydon the borough that i represent uh
the labour council there has gone
bankrupt because the first london
borough to go bankrupt in 25 years
because they engaged in reckless
property speculation they bought a hotel
that then went bust those sort of local
issues i think do play a very important
role as well but the national issues
clearly play a part in all of this as
well i mean we're reading stevens
winford in the times this morning at
quoting a senior official who's seen the
sue grey report who says it is so
damning that the prime minister should
the prime minister may go as a result i
mean you know conservatives are pretty
happy that sue gray isn't reporting this
side of the election
well i'm not going to speculate about
what this report may or may not say well
obviously i'm sure debate it very amply
when it gets uh when it gets published
um but as i say we're talking to i've
been out on about croydon this weekend
uh all day yesterday for example and
people are focused rightly on local
issues we're electing local councils to
run local authorities and the issues
people are focusing on are who you know
which party who is best to run your
local council in the case of croydon the
appalling bankrupt uh labour
administration i you know i think
deserves to be voted out and i hope they
will be but it's not just it's not just
the electorate that perhaps are going to
give the conservatives a bit of a
kicking at the moment i mean last week
when the government tried to delay the
investigation the privileges committee
investigation i mean were you given a
call by by the chief whip i mean did the
chief whip say to you that he wanted you
to vote to delay that i mean what was
your response to that well i think there
was obviously a bit of a debate that
went on about whether the debate was
over whether the vote is all a bit
technical over whether the vote to refer
to the privileged committee should have
should have happened last week whether
the vote should have happened after the
uh police investigations and the sugar
report had concluded that was the debate
it's a rather uh technical nuanced
debate technical on the one hand you had
the government wanting the amendment
putting forward an amendment you know to
delay to delay the investigation which
they then pulled half an hour before the
vote yeah well it was the debate about
when to have the vote and they decided
that
since the prime minister felt he had
nothing to hide and doesn't mind even
more scrutiny this will be by the way
the third investigation you've got the
police one the two grey one now this one
is a third one uh he said he had nothing
to hide and therefore uh doesn't mind
parliament uh performing whatever
scrutiny that he wants to so they just
got on with it and had the vote last
thursday which as it turned out was and
it wasn't a vote at all it was
completely uncontested and not a single
person voted against it so it turned out
to be um a non-uh non-controversy chris
good to have you in the studio this
morning thanks for joining thank you
uh we are now going to return to the
border of poland and ukraine uh listen
to i think the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken i just returned from
keeve
where we went at the request of
president biden and the invitation of
president zelinski
we had an opportunity to demonstrate
directly
our strong support our strong ongoing
support
for the ukrainian government
and for the ukrainian people
this was in our judgment an important
moment uh to be there
an important moment for for ukraine for
the war
an important moment to have
face-to-face conversations in detail
about the
[Music]
extraordinary
support that we provided
security economic humanitarian
as well as the massive pressure that
we've been exerting on russia and then
to talk in detail about how we carry
that forward
across all of those fronts
i would say that
without putting words in his mouth uh
president zielinski
expressed a deep appreciation
for president biden's leadership and for
the incredible generosity and support of
the american people
in turn
we expressed
deep admiration
for his leadership
for
the extraordinary courage
of ukrainians in standing up to
and pushing back this russian aggression
um of our commitment going forward
involves a number of things that i was
able to share with president zolensky
yesterday including the return of
american diplomats to ukraine starting
next week
uh including
president biden's intent to nominate a
new ambassador to ukraine ambassador
bridget brink currently
an ambassador someone i've served with
for a long time deeply experienced in
the region he'll be a very strong
representative for the united states in
ukraine
we had an opportunity as well to
talk about
where this goes from here um
with the success that ukraine has had
it's also true that russia continues to
try to brutalize parts of the country
and the death and destruction that we
continue to see is horrific but
ukrainians are standing up they're
standing strong and they're doing that
with the support that we have
coordinated uh from literally around the
world
the strategy that we've put in place
massive support for ukraine
massive pressure against russia
solidarity
with more than 30 countries
engaged in these efforts
is having real results
and we're seeing that when it comes to
russia's war aims
russia is failing
ukraine is succeeding
russia has sought
our security and defense editor debra
haynes is live in the ukrainian capital
for us morning again deborah um what do
you make of that which we heard from
anthony blinken i mean the ukrainians
are crying out for assistance they've
been crying out for assistance since the
start of this indeed they've been crying
out for assistance since long before
conflict started
yes and they are getting that assistance
and the fact is um the ukrainian
military was able to defend kiev in the
way that they did prevent russian forces
from seizing the capital in large part
thanks to the weapons they received from
allies like the us like the uk and
others but of course as the secretary of
state and the defense secretary were
spelling out they're still giving their
press conference now actually um the the
requirement from the ukrainian side is
evolving as the war evolves so
russia has changed its strategy it's
moved its forces out from the north of
ukraine and it's now focusing in the
east uh in the north there's a lot of
forestry um the terrain is very
different in the east it's open plains
and that's why the need now is for tanks
for heavy artillery for long-range guns
he talks about the howitzers which are
being very well received here in ukraine
and also the need to sustain this uh
this support on tuesday the u.s defense
secretary is going to be hosting a
meeting in germany on an air base there
where other allies are going to be
meeting with him talking about the
continued support that they need to give
to ukraine
deborah thanks very much indeed
now the health secretary i said a
hormone replacement therapy are will be
appointed the shortages of medication
have reportedly left some women feeling
suicidal the announcement comes as
recent figures suggest the number of hrt
prescriptions in the uk has doubled in
the last five years but stocks well
those aren't running low our reporter
madeleine radcliff joins us from the
newsroom now with more on this uh
madeline explain exactly why we are in
such a problem with getting hold of this
hrt medication and what indeed a czar
can do about it well
the shortages have come from for several
reasons first of all there's a global
increase in demand for the drugs they're
patches or gels or pills even that help
combat some of the very varied symptoms
um when you're going through the
menopause so it's no wonder that they're
popular but increased global demand and
then of course we've heard so much about
supply chain problems it affects these
drugs as well we know that there have
been manufacturing issues that then
meets um still some kinks in the supply
chain some of the biggest manufacturers
of the gels have said that they've had
shortages and
have been struggling to get enough of
the stuff and then on at a local level
that meets
the differences between local health
authorities what they offer some have a
offer fewer hrt options and so across
the board that leads to what we've heard
women sharing their prescriptions
struggling to get enough of it the
shortages we think have been going on
the last few weeks into a month or so
now what does r can do um sajid javed
hopes or says the role will be modeled
on kate bingham's incredibly successful
chairing of the vaccine task force so
obviously that helped uh get the vaccine
rolled out across uh the uk incredibly
quickly was widely seen as one of the
great successes of the pandemic and the
idea is similar to that so it'll be
someone who can oversee the supply
the supply chain on a macro level and
then all the way down to a more local
level make sure those bits work together
make sure the money is going to the
right areas
in terms of research and innovation so
we can only hope it will be as
successful as kate bingham's chairing
with the vaccine task force
madeline thanks very much indeed
now there are growing concerns that the
chinese government could order the
capital beijing into lockdown to try and
contain an outbreak of covet it comes as
shanghai reports 51 new deaths among its
covert patients
let's speak at disguise asia
correspondent tom cheshire who is in
beijing for us and for the time being at
least outside there must be plenty of
concern there
given what we have seen in shanghai as
to what might be coming down the
pipeline for beijing
yeah neil people are very worried here
and the reason they're worried is
because of what's happening behind me
now this is mass testing so there have
been about 19 cases in chao yang
district which is the district where
uh where lots of people live three and a
half million people live they all have
to go and get tested now the line
today is
in the morning uh local time
still
lines here and because this is what
happened in shanghai to start with uh
people are worried in shanghai they said
they're going to mass test people and
then since they've been
down the entire time uh and that was
about the same thing happening here if
you go to supermarkets the shelves are
all empty the government has said there
are enough food
aren't france based on
they saw in shanghai because shanghai
now entering the fifth week of lockdown
as you say 51 deaths reported that's the
highest in a difference the early days
of the woohound outbreak the most
concerning thing though is that cases
there are still around 20 000 a day so
they haven't been going up but they're
not coming down so the idea that ending
soon i don't think that is going to
happen so people in beijing worried
about the same fate now the quality of
that is perhaps we've seen other cities
in china like
mini lockdowns short sharp lockdowns and
they've done it when case numbers are
slower and as a result have been able to
come out of them quicker so a lot of
people think that's what's going to
happen here wait for case
impossible situation that shanghai has
seen try and get on top of this quickly
and lock down quickly it's clear that
when you test three and a half million
people you are going to find a lot more
cases i think anything more than 100
would precipitate some sort of lockdown
in this area and the question then
becomes how long does it last is there
enough food for everyone and the bigger
question is this the right strategy long
term covert zero dynamic covert zero as
china calls it it hasn't vaccinated much
of its elderly population compared to
other countries so it's still relying on
lockdowns more than two and a half years
into the pandemic
tom for now many thanks indeed
let's take a look at some of the day's
other headlines now and a cross-party
group of mps have criticized corvord
travel restrictions as disproportionate
to the risks to public health in a wide
ranging and highly critical report
westminster's transport select committee
say that the government's travel rules
caused a severe financial shock to the
sector without significant health
benefits we'll be chatting to the chair
of that committee a little later in the
programme
police have arrested a man in his
fifties in connection with the
disappearance of a woman in burnley 33
year old katie kenyon has not been seen
by her family since last friday and
she's believed to have left an address
on the town's todd morgan road
an outbreak of ebola has been declared
in the democratic republic of congo four
months after the last one ended the
world health organization says it is the
third outbreak in the northwestern uh
province since 2018. so far only one
case has been confirmed
at least one person has died and three
firefighters have been injured by
wildfires in the u.s state of nebraska
the wind-driven wildfires have also
destroyed hundreds of structures in
northern new mexico and forced thousands
to flee
you want to have a look at this uh
stagecoach they are road testing the
uk's first fully autonomous bus as you
can see written there the vehicles are
equipped with sensors which enable them
to run on pre-selected roads without the
driver having to take control how can he
stand sitting at the wheel with his
hands by his side uh well they hope to
carry passengers over the fourth road
bridge from fife to edinburgh by this
summer will you be on board
i'm not so sure let's have a quick look
at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar
airways and the week ahead is looking
mostly dry with sunny spells and light
winds however it will be on the cool
side with a return of nighttime frosts
at largely dry but chile first thing
this morning with a touch of frost in
sheltered parts of the north and west
low clouds in the northeast will burn
back to the coast this morning to leave
sunny spells but scattered showers will
develop through the day temperatures
will those will be down a notch although
it will feel warm enough in the sunshine
with lighter winds than of late
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back just a reminder as to our
top stories this morning and emmanuel
macron has won a second term as
president beating his far right
challenger marine le pen but protests
have broken out in cities across france
as the president sets out to heal a
divided nation
[Music]
the u.s has pledged more money for
ukraine's military after a meeting
between america's secretary of state
anthony blinken and president zielenski
and the government has outlined new
plans to give football fans more of a
say in how their clubs are run
now mps across the political divides
have condemned an article in the mail on
sunday about labour's deputy leader and
they've condemned it as sexist and
misogynistic earlier i asked the
technology minister chris philp about
the story which claimed miss rainer had
been distracting boris johnson at prime
minister's questions
by crossing and uncrossing her legs he
told me that he was appalled
i was appalled that um that sentiment
was being expressed it's offensive uh
it's misogynistic the prime minister and
cabinet ministers have been absolutely
right to roundly condemn that sentiment
and to offer support to angela uh rayner
on this issue i've never heard anyone uh
say anything like that or even hinted it
and if i did i would be disgusted and
appalled nobody should have to
suffer the kind of misogynistic um abuse
which that sentiment amounts to
as you can see our political
correspondent tomorrow is here in the
studio morning tamara um it's appalling
it's misogynistic but aside from a
whatsapp message and a couple of fairly
identical looking tweets i mean what are
the government doing about this um it's
pretty clear that number 10 feel that
this is all they are going to do about
it um it's been pointed out to me that
boris johnson contacted angela rainer
personally on whatsapp yesterday i'm
told he sent her a short but heartfelt
message and that she graciously replied
although i've not been told exactly what
was in the message other than him saying
it was not in his name this was not
something that he was putting about by
any means um it's also been pointed out
to me by another friend of the prime
minister that he was very angry about um
his wife being referred to as princess
nut nut in some other briefings to
newspapers by his former advisors about
a year and a half ago so the idea being
that he um under takes misogyny quite
seriously and quite personally and um
conveyed that to angela rayner but as
far as number 10 is concerned he's uh
condemned it it's been condemned by
conservatives pretty roundly and that is
the end of it when you ask chris felt
whether there be an internal inquiry or
anything he just he called it abuse but
he said they would be going no further
in terms of an attempt to get the
journalists to have their past revoked
from parliament i don't think labour or
the conservatives support that on free
speech grounds it's a matter of taste
really
tomorrow for now thanks very much indeed
let's head back to sophie she's in paris
and has all the latest on the french
election results
interesting night sophie
yeah it certainly was an interesting
night and really the margin for victory
are bigger than many had expected but
that does mask i think some divisions in
the country and emmanuel macron has
vowed to unite what he sees as a divide
of france after becoming the first
french president in 20 years to be
re-elected he saw of course that
challenge from the far-right candidate
marine le pen to get a second term
now the election results give macron
58.54
of the vote while marine le pen has
41.46
and mr macron has already been
congratulated by other world leaders
including boris johnson the dutch prime
minister and also the president of the
european commission while his supporters
gathered in the shadow of the eiffel
tower to celebrate and hear him address
the crowds
with me now is our europe correspondent
to adam parsons it feels like before we
get to the caveat it's right to
acknowledge the scale of the victory
yeah i think you're right and i think i
think both of those things are right
sophie
i mean a 17 percentage point victory in
a two-horse race it is very wide i've
just been looking at the figures it's
the third biggest victory ever uh going
uh the worst ever was jean-marie le pen
the second worst was marine le pen five
years ago and now we have this one so a
manual macro one by this yawning margin
and it's a bigger margin than any of the
poles are predicted and interesting over
the past week or so at one point it was
into well into single digits and it's
got wider and wider it feels like it in
the past week something happened
there are a lot of french elect
voters sat back looked at these two
candidates and thought
do i really love either of them probably
not
but which one do i dislike less and it
appears that the one that they thought
was the safer more palatable option
was uh was emmanuel macron but as you
said this is this is not an election
where people are out on the streets
jubilant celebrating you know the
returning hero
it is very much the case as we heard a
lot of times in the campaign of a choice
between cholera and the plague and in
the end they went uh they went to
macaron yeah thank you uh very much uh
adam we'll have a quick look at some of
the
papers and have a look at how some of
those french papers are actually
covering
president macron's uh win
well this is the figaro which splashes
with a triumphant president macron
calling his victory historic their
headline big victory big
challengers
liberation asks who mr macron has to
thank for his re-election suggesting
that it's mainly due to a protest vote
against the far right
but le monde is a bit more muted they
leave their website say it was a victory
without triumph overshadowed by the
record performance
by the far right
well macron supporters were celebrating
his uh
victory uh last night uh as you can see
there
a victory that was really quite muted in
some ways he was much more of a humble
sense i think of uh compared to the
victory that he had
back in 2017 and perhaps an
acknowledgement there from mr macron
that there were people who supported his
policies but he was also
elected to power uh by those who
effectively lent him their votes to in
his words act as a barrier uh to the far
right so
an emphatic victory but with some
caveats turnout uh the lowest that it's
been since 1969 which i think perhaps
gives you a sense about some of the
unpopularity of the two candidates in
the final runoff
well with me now is the national uh
rallies candidates um i shouldn't say
candid a counsellor patricia
and thank you very much for being with
us today
disappointing night for you
it's of course always a disappointment
you don't don't enter an election um to
lose right to enter an election to win
but the
defeat yesterday really actually hides a
great victory a great victory because
never so many people voted for marine le
pen um there were 17 million voters for
our party yesterday in france um i think
it's very important to realize that the
abstention rate was tremendously high in
in france uh 16 million people did not
go to the to the polls and there were
another two million who actually cast
blank votes
for this election um i think the result
that we see from this election yesterday
is a new division in french society we
definitely have now on the one hand um
mr mccall his
globalist view of the world
who was voted in by urban people um
a lot of the cartier the bulgaria as we
say in france where mr melancho voted
but we might get back to that and we see
that marine level le pen has constantly
consolidated her votes
in rural france and amongst the young
generation which is very interesting
because the young generation of course
is upcoming while we see that mr mccall
got the votes of the 65 plus uh which of
course is a generation which is outgoing
i just want to come back to what you
said at the beginning saying that you
lost but it was actually a great victory
i mean that seems almost quite orwellian
to me i mean if you look at the results
you got absolutely trounced macron got
58.5 percent compared to 41.5 in what
land is that a great victory we nearly
gained 10
um back from 2017 so the idea you lost
but slightly less badly that's not a
victory no it's 10 more that's huge that
is absolutely huge if you see the
difference between 2017 and 2022 and
it's nearly a 10
nearly a 10 gain in in voters but that's
also partly because the unpopularity of
macron you said yourself the abstention
rate was extremely high this is a man
who's seen as arrogant as a president of
the rich and yet he's still managed to
track marine le pen yeah i don't think
that's the only reason for the
abstention
for the abstention i think the reason
for the abstention is that we did not
have a proper presidential debate mr
marco only entered the campaign very
late he waited until the last day to
declare his candidacy and he only had
one single debate he refused to
participate in the national debates with
the 12 candidates and i think a lot of
people were left
very disappointed because there was no
proper
presidential debate about two very
different projects for france and they
decided not to go because there was no
presidential debate so i think that the
abstention rate shows the um
disappointment the disapproval maybe
even the disgust of the french people
with french politics as you know
including the far-right candidate i'm
seeing general politics in general
because we have a two-tier system for
voting for the presidential elections we
have a two-tier system voting very
shortly for our national assembly and
that means for example that
in 2017 with over 40 percent of the
votes
has seven members of parliament in
france
i mean that is crazy right so that
disappoints a lot of people and i think
this election shows that it's really
time to start changing the electoral
system in france have a more
proportional system so the french people
feel involved in politics let's talk a
bit about uh those uh elections because
as you said they're coming up in june
aren't they it's going to be a big focus
for lots of the parties and how hopeful
are you that the right the far right are
going to get seats from the national
assembly
oh it's going to be very interesting a
battle i think that the vote that was
cast yesterday if you look at the media
in the two weeks prior to the the second
round
i did not see one newspaper asking to
vote for marine le pen although i saw
many newspapers clearly saying we must
vote macron so i think what's going to
happen now in the in the elections the
um general assembly elections will be in
june
i think the french people are going to
want a proper opposition they don't want
mac hall to have the yellow to call out
the yellow vests again in the street
they want more protection so i think the
french people will vote in their members
of parliament in a very different way
and what next for the far right marine
le pen has this is her third attempt at
the presidency is it time for her to
step back and allow new faces to come
forward i think the question is um of
course we are going to sit down
everybody is going to sit down and
discuss the results of the elections and
analyze them as i said before i find
great choice in when i look at the
numbers of young people that voted for
us marine le pen
really just had the best scores with the
young with the young people of france
and that's very encouraging it does mean
that uh the young generation wants to
change we all change but not necessarily
the far right you know i i do have to
come back
this is an election where you know
you're 41.5 percent of the vote against
an unpopular president many people would
see this as a rejection of the far right
and the policies of the far right uh yes
there has been some incremental change
but overall this is a far worse result
than you're expecting
sophie you do not live in france in in
rural france where i come from and where
i'm elected there is a great division in
france between people who live in urban
areas like like in paris who can afford
you know apartments with 20 000 30 000
euros a square meter and the rest of
france who have to get by on a minimum
wage which is the majority of the french
people people who are working who are
living and working in the countryside
where the petrol prices have exploded
where the public transport has gone
where there is no more health care where
sometimes you have to travel for an hour
to see a gp
those people have voted massively for
mad independent if you see the french
countryside voted massively so as i told
you before what this election really
teaches us is there is a great division
between urban france and rural france a
huge division so i understand where
you're coming from but of course rural
france is not so populated so the impact
of voters and cities is very high and
it's interesting
yes of course this is more people um but
um we have uh we have seen on the voting
maps that it's urban big urban areas
with wealthy people who have benefited
from a globalization but also the
bonjour where of course mr melancho
who you're not talking about it but
who's the third runner-up extreme left
in france
woke left
trotsky's left he also did much better
than expected yes he was the great
surprise of this election he was
actually the great surprise of this
election and he got the majority of his
votes in the uh in the in the suburbs or
what we call the hot suburbs where we
have all those problems with um drugs
immigration crime organized crime okay
uh thank you very much we are at a time
uh there uh great victory uh for at the
far right uh according to uh patricia on
well that is all uh from us for now uh
in uh paris and vatic a victory for
emmanuel macron but as we said uh the
lowest turnout since 1969 uh perhaps
revealing a bit of dissatisfaction with
both the candidates in the final run-off
factory nathaniel
sophie thank you lots more of course
from paris throughout the day
but let's change directions somewhat and
netflix remember them well they're axing
their own original shows much earlier
than scheduled in reaction to their
sudden loss of subscribers fans are
furious over the call as fewer than one
in five netflix originals are reaching
their third season let's have a look at
some of them
if it pleases your greatness you may
take my son
father what are you doing
father
this will not be forever
the walls of my kingdom stretch beyond
the horizon report what you see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my pleasure
[Applause]
oh joining us to discuss the tech
journalist will guys live from his tech
shed as always good to see you this
morning will and good morning if you
read the papers this weekend you would
have assumed that netflix was entirely
on its uppers that it was on its way out
that it had already died to death i
suspect we're being a little premature
what's your view
yeah i think people are being slightly
premature because netflix were the first
and they're the first to make this huge
pivot the reality is there's too many
streaming services and if you don't have
um product or shows that people want to
watch on those services people soon turn
off because it's it's either get a
netflix subscription or eat in some
people's cases so there's a cost of
living situation going on here and i
also think probably from my uh my view
and i've got the arcade machines behind
me i don't necessarily think that
netflix has made the greatest views on
what its programming are it's trying to
broaden its audience at the moment it's
trying to move away from the people like
me who love the adam sandler films and
that's an important stat because they
made they invested millions of dollars
in adam sandler because they knew their
viewers were watching adam sandler films
we were all questioning why they were
doing it but it was because they have
all the statistics about who was
watching what and when they were
watching it so they're very savvy at
deciding what comes and what goes
perhaps much quicker than other
broadcasters because they're getting all
of this instant feedback yeah but
you you say all of that okay they've got
the access to the instant data they have
access to more money than god i mean
they've spent tens of billions over the
past couple of years to get the
programmes out there and still
they're shedding subscribers
yeah and that's the cost of living
versus the cost of streaming it's one of
the first things that goes because you
don't have a long subscription the
reality is five years ago i had a sky
subscription and i probably i may have
had one other one other streaming
subscription then now in 2022 i've got
at least five streaming subscriptions
alongside my sky subscription and the
cost of viewing has not stayed in line
you're now paying an additional amount
of money for all of these services and i
think that's the challenge here is none
of them have yet reached the sweet spot
netflix has this incredible habit of
increasing the price when i started
watching netflix i think i was paying a
fiver a month i think it's now about 15
pounds a month so there's this
increasing cost and the other thing
that's been largely unspoken about with
netflix till now and they're now
speaking about it is the number of
people sharing a password they say
they're now in 220 million homes where
they have subscribers but they've also
now admitted they've got 100 million
people watching subscriptions twice so
they may have 300 million people
watching but only 200 million people
globally are paying and this is going to
be the next big issue everybody who's
been lending a lending in quotation
marks a password to other people are
going to find soon they're going to be
locked out
well we've got 30 seconds but you know
we're already hearing from netflix
they're talking about perhaps moving to
a lower individual cost mode
model but with some advertising i mean i
don't know about you but that sounds an
awful lot like television
that's an awful idea i'd seen a sit and
watch a film on any other channel where
you don't get that disrupt disruption
netflix are also moving into video
gaming as well which shows you perhaps
the streaming of films and tv content
might not be the only place where they
want to be
well always good to see you and indeed
batman you might want to stay tuned
for a couple of stories later on the
show for now thanks very much
let's have a quick look at a couple of
the picture stories in the telegraph a
picasso painting owned by the late sean
connery why on earth do you think i went
for this story well it's set to fetch a
massive
million pounds when it comes up at
auction the former double 07 has a
philanthropic fund in his name so
some of the money raised from this
painting will be donated to its
charities and in part some of the most
bizarre news you'll hear today the son
has an image of a woman who has
married her cat the happy couple oh god
alive uh tied the knot in order to
prevent landlords asking her to get rid
of the feline a true tale of true love
and love is clearly in the air as back
with the telegraph they have a picture
of two newlyweds who took part in the
malden mud race in essex yesterday i'm
hoping their honeymoon will involve a
shower and possibly a dry cleaner we
will see you at eight o'clock when we'll
have all the latest from paris as
emmanuel macron wins another town
[Music]